that's fantastic man
we are live okay today today's guest i
got i just wanna tell you who today's
guess is today's guess is john e deaton
former marine in the marines he was a
lawyer okay in the marines he comes out
he starts uh falling in love for the
concept of crypto give or take he's
interested in what's going on with the
technology and the coin
and then uh from there
when the sec goes after xrp ripple i
think december of last year it's when
they open up the case
uh
john e deaton is now representing 62 000
xrp holders of which a thousand of them
own other coins as well a lot of people
on twitter were saying you and i got to
get together
and we finally were able to make it work
so if you're somebody that's following
crypto if you own bitcoin if you own
ethereum if you own ripple if you own
anything you probably want to pay
attention to this and we're aware that a
lot of the xrp community is going to be
here because there's a cult-like
following with that community so thanks
for having me on man thank you thanks
for coming on appreciate it okay so
having said that before before we get
into it uh can you get some of the guys
to give me an ipad charger here because
this thing literally does because i've
been watching a bunch of his interviews
so john
what's going on okay currently right now
with the sec case against ripple we have
a bunch of notes here but bring
everybody up to date on what's going on
right now with the lawsuit well right
now we're waiting on a couple big
decisions from the judge there's a
decision a motion to strike ripples fair
notice defense and a motion the most
important motion i believe because i
think the fair notice one's going to be
an easy one for them to decide it is the
internal documents at the scc the their
documents on bitcoin their documents on
ethereum there's even a document dated
june 13 2018 on evaluating xrp and
whether it's a security and the sec has
refused to turn any of these documents
over they're claiming they're privileged
and they're claiming they're privileged
pat
even though they claim that they've
never made an official declaration on
bitcoin or ethereum they've actually
rescinded bill hinman's speech in june
on june 14 2018 where he said look ether
is no longer a security bitcoin's not a
security they've all
walked away from that and so that's why
this case is so important if the sec
successful i can guarantee you gary
gensler is coming after ether
potentially and not so much bitcoin but
every other altcoin so so there's three
audiences you're talking to today so i
just want to kind of give you this
perspective so you know as you're
communicating
the typical audience you talk to they're
all crypto community so when you drop in
names and all this stuff they know right
so when you drop in verbiage they know
uh when you're saying certain things
they know today's community is consisted
of those who are xrp ripple which you're
very comfortable talking to them number
two it's the community on the crypto
side that don't own xrp but they own
bitcoin and ethereum
and they're concerned about what's gonna
happen with you because not you they're
concerned what's gonna happen with this
case because we know gary is hired and
appointed i think february 3rd of this
year by kamala and biden as the sec
chair
and he used to be the the commodity
futures trade commission under obama
before and then prior to that he was
under clinton so he's a full-blown
democrat they know it and we know kamala
biden uh one of the game plans that they
had is they were there was a couple
things that were not comfortable about
is why they brought gary and gary is not
a fan of spax they're trying to little
over-regulate specs you're aware of that
because last year there was about a
hundred billion dollars of money raised
for specs the last 24 months so spax
aren't the up and come they've been
around for a while but it's been a lot
of momentum lately and the other thing
they're worried that they cannot
regulate is why they brought gary in is
cryptocurrency they would like to figure
out a way to make
crypto a security because if they do
they can now control it they can now you
know regulate it they can do a lot of
different things so for the audience
that has no clue what's going on okay no
clue what's going on
let's go through
uh uh
your initial passion on why you
as a former marine lawyer who's
extremely skeptical
why did you all of a sudden say look man
i want to see what's going on here with
crypto this is kind of interesting to me
what was appealing to you all right well
first thing i did i did what a lot of
people do i read the bitcoin white paper
okay
fell in love with the concept of
cryptocurrency bought bitcoin bought
ethereum bought xrp and just sort of
went
a firm believer you know i think you
said in an episode 40
of all u.s dollars printed in the last
one year yep 18 months it's staggering
and so looking as an alternative a hedge
on inflation or just an alternative to
fiat currency that's being debased every
day right so that's what got me involved
what got me involved in this suit pat
was i'm just an investor i'm not a
securities lawyer believe it or not i'm
actually amicus counsel in the biggest
securities case since
1946 and i've been practicing a
securities law for about
nine months right but when i read the
complaint as an xrp holder i learned
that the case was filed i was expecting
to see what you always see in these
securities cases that the sec would say
you know what brad garland house you
know what ripple when you sold xrp in
2013 to 2015 on this specific
transaction on that specific date that
was an unregistered security
and that's what i expected first
paragraph xrp itself is a digital asset
security and it's an unregistered
security from the very beginning of time
until today so according to scc
including the secondary market pat
if i go right now and i buy xrp from
uphold and i don't have any idea of
ripple
they're saying that's an unregistered
security and so it's something very
different they're attacking trying to
set a precedent against the token itself
and the case the seminole case that they
go off is this case called howie from
the supreme court in 1946 it involved
orange groves and the sec never said or
the supreme court never said the oranges
are the securities they said the scheme
and the marketing and the packaging the
way that
the company
sold it that was an unregistered
securities offering they didn't say the
tracks of land were the security they
didn't say the oranges were the security
the underlying instrument pat is never
the security it's the way you offer it
and package it but in this particular
case they went after the token and pat
for eight years it was sold in the
united states and worldwide two hundred
exchanges
they allowed ripple to purchase nine
percent of money gram
they had a settlement with finsin in
2015 where they called it digital
convertible virtual currency this was
being allowed to go on and on and on and
all of a sudden
the former sec chairman jay clayton on
his last day as he's walking out the
door
slaps this lawsuit the most significant
sec enforcement action in my opinion in
modern history in a non-fraud case
and goes after the token and there's so
many conflicts of interest that we're
going to get into jay clayton was just
on tv today on cnbc and and they asked
him again what about these conflicts
that everyone is uh calling you out on
and he's like i'm not going to talk
about it because it's pending litigation
there's no pending litigation over your
ethics right but he refuses to answer
these questions stuff we're going to get
into yeah so so the the and by the way
the current uh of the case against sec
doesn't xrp have like some of the most
incredible
team right now the former sec chairman
is one of their representative who do
they have on their team right now who's
ripple off on their team right now it's
outstanding yeah that's what that's
married
mary jo white former sec chairwoman
former sec chairwoman's on on their team
yeah former director of enforcement a
guy named andrew ceresney who is the
director of enforcement is their lead
trial attorney this is ripples yeah and
they also have uh uh on their team
former scc uh person in charge of new
york's office and they actually have
someone who used to be the director of
corporation and finance on their team
ripple has an all-star
team as far as defending this case so so
let's let's uh let's talk about the
devil's advocate okay the folks who are
right now saying well ripple deserves
this because behind closed doors they
were doing x y z and for the way ripple
was formatted if i remember
eighty percent of that a hundred billion
right is it a hundred billion tokens
they might send it correctly of which
eighty percent they gifted 20 they kept
right right today's market cap is around
37 billion dollars the fully diluted
will be around 80 billion dollars it's
kind of where they are today correct
with numbers so
some people from the other side say well
listen these guys were kind of doing a
pump and dump type of stuff behind
closed doors and yeah manipulation and
because there's no regulation they can
kind of do this and you know they used
to say that also about uh
john mcafee john mcafee would say it's
going to this let's go into this it's
going to this it would go up he would
sell then he would tell people not to
sell and i don't know whether he did
this or not but that was a lot of
criticism because we had mcafee on as
well well one of the big things that you
know we talked in the crypto community
our guys are like we love ripple the
technology we love ripple the coin we
love what it can do for you know
international you know uh money
transactions hate the people who created
it
so like that's that seems why is that
though why why are people saying that
though well i think because when you
compare it to like bitcoin right
there was no pre mine with
bitcoin yeah
and
you had people allegedly could fairly
mine for it and it was open and was
decentralized from the beginning
they they believe that these executives
are enriching themselves but my answer
to that question is okay go after brad
garden house go after ripple why are you
going after the token why are you eight
years after the fact by going after the
teacher that put you know 500 in the
ripple yeah exactly i've never met brad
garland house never met chris larson
never met the
any of the people at ripple i'm no
ripple fan those two names that you just
so if people don't know their founders i
think chris is the one that founded
ripple uh labs right he's one of the
co-founders as well yes and and they
were sued independently now they the
thing about it pat is in this case after
a 30-month investigation the sec didn't
actually allege fraud
they investigated ripple for 30 months
there's no fraud
alleged it is a strict securities
violation you didn't give proper
disclosures when you made these
transactions and and i say fine go after
them all right i'm not here to defend
them they've got way better lawyers than
me right to defend them but what you're
doing
when you go after the token itself in
the secondary market right you're let me
tell you something and i know this
because i've been communicating with 60
000 people
it is an absolute fact that the first
time purchasers of xrp
58.2 of them had never heard of the
company ripple they've heard ripple the
name but they never heard of a company
58 percent have never heard when they
pure speculation yeah you know what they
do listen you go on you it was a number
three for a while it was number two
market cap but it's the top three market
cap somewhere like cryptocurrencies it's
25 cents so people look at it they see
bitcoin going up they're like hey i can
afford 25 cents right and so so they
were doing that and had no connection to
this company and so to to allege
that those people entered a common
enterprise with ripple and therefore
it's an investment contract is just it's
taking absurdity to the highest level
do you think that they attacked a soft
target do you think that that they were
looking to set a precedent against the
tokens ripple made the mistake of
incorporating in the united states
and they went after people that they
didn't think like who pays you like like
they never thought that you know 60 000
coin holders would actually come
together communicate and formulate some
sort of defense against this they
thought they were going after a soft
target and that they were going to
create some case law that was going to
change the crypto landscape and then you
came in and you you you took a dump on
their front lawn well let me tell you i
think what we're talking about here the
people that you know in cryptocurrency
where and what pat said about people
don't like these executives or they
don't like the 80 percent being gifted
and holding back 20
if you read the complaint even though
they don't allege fraud
they use fraud like language in the
complaint and it inflames people if you
don't like ripple and you're like oh
they're going after ripple i'm not
worried about it but when you read the
complaint and it says that all xrp
holders
all joined into a common enterprise with
each other and with ripple when they say
that the very nature of the token itself
is an investment contract with ripple
then it becomes very dangerous they're
using in my opinion this case to set the
precedent that you're talking about so
that if they're successful they can do
what you were saying pat and regulate
all the cryptocurrency so so so let's go
back to this sec lawsuit that uh uh
clayton you said clayton did right
before the day before he was done he
absolutely filed this lawsuit i think
it's december 20th of 2020 december
something of 2020 right after election
by the woman this thing kind of took
place
so
so the lawsuit is towards the exhaust
xrp holders
nothing to do with brad and chris is
that what you're saying or are they
going after brad and chris as well
separately no they're going after ripple
and brad and chris but they're being so
over broad in their language that
they're using that they're saying all
xrp even in the secondary market
that's being traded that all of that's
an unregistered security so one of these
62 000 that's uh what did they get in
mail did they get and mail something
from the sec did they get
how do they know they're being part of
that lawsuit okay what happened was
basically and and this was forewarned
clayton and i have a letter i'm going to
give it to you because i just got it
from the scc after fighting them for
nine months
and threatening to sue them through a
freedom of information act but a former
fellow republican sec commissioner joe
grundfest on december 17th
he
sent a letter to clayton and the
commissioners and said
don't do this you are about to harm
innocent xrp holders and cause more
billions in losses than in any non-fraud
case in the history of this country they
warned them and they still found it on
walking out the door and so what
happened is just as that former sec
commissioner warned he said listen if
you say the xrp is unregistered security
coinbase is trying to go public
they're not going to hold it they're not
going to keep it they're not going to
trade it and so the intermediaries the
exchanges and the platforms are going to
delist it and that's what happened and
so coinbase they're kraken binance
crypto.com they all said look i'm not
messing with the sec sec says the token
itself is unregistered security we're
delisting it and we're not trading it
and so you have people
uh learn that way and many of these xrp
holders learned of this company named
ripple and these executives called brad
garland house and chris larson
for the first time when they got notice
on their wallet and coinbase that said
pursuant to the and it says i can show
you on my phone it says because of the
sec action against ripple we are
suspending all trading of xrp and let me
tell you how that impacts people pat
i don't know if you've ever heard of i
trust capital right it's basically an
ira for crypto and it's the biggest one
in the country and they allow you to
hold your crypto just like you can have
the bitcoin grayscale bitcoin trust in
an ira right
well they basically have frozen
all of the people's assets so xrp if
they want to trade it right now they
can't if they want to sell it because
xrp goes to five bucks and and take that
gain they can't this is robin hood gme
all over again i mean that's what you
can't buy or sell or trade right now you
ca not on coinbase on those there are a
couple exchanges like uphold that made
the decision that said this is ludicrous
our securities lawyers say there's not a
unregistered security we're comfortable
maintaining it but there's like one or
two out of 15 and the rest of them
de-listed and but those individuals who
have that money that xrp it's frozen so
if they had a life-altering event
right their their mother-in-law needed
to go to a nursing home and they needed
the cash couldn't touch it can't touch
it yeah all waiting on this lawsuit to
happen couldn't touch well that's that's
a uh that's how a lot of these
organizations get uh
you know negative
uh uh
reputation that they do scc types of
organizations what i'm talking about but
you know when you get a knock on the
door from sec that's a real knock yeah
it's not just anybody knocking on your
door that's a knock you gotta answer and
say here we go again so how much money
is ripple right now brad chris how much
are they using with legal teams
especially the killer the ridiculous
legal team that they have how much have
they already spent do you know i don't
know but i wouldn't be surprised if it's
at least a million and a half a month
okay million and a half a month is what
they're spending i mean that's that's me
guessing so so so in in full you know if
you were to say right now there's a few
things that can happen right with this
case
they can settle which a lot of people
are saying is probably going to end up
settling right let's just say it's going
to end up settling the sec comes and
let's settle you know 10 million bucks
50 million bucks 100 million bucks
whatever the number is that they settle
with right fine here's a check you move
on
and then the other one is to say they
release they just kind of say look we're
just going to let it go we're not going
to do anything right now
and uh we're not necessarily going to
settle with you
what is the consequences of both both
negative and positive
well i think it's very positive for
everyone if there is a settlement and
and
give you an example you could pick the
number
ripple owns 50 billion xrp it's in
escrow and each month 1 billion gets
released and they use some of it sell it
and then they put it back in escrow
that's 50 billion pat
imagine if xrp gets to five bucks
right
there worth 250 billion dollars that's
significantly more than morgan stanley
and goldman sachs and so if that were to
happen and the scc were to be worried
about the precedent right the way this
case settles is gary ginsler is afraid
that an adverse ruling by the judge on
fair notice where she says listen you
can't go after him you let it happen for
eight years uh you didn't do anything
there's so much unclarity in the world
in this market uh you allowed them to
have money gram you allowed it to go on
coinbase all those things
if that happens then that precedent
would be usable by cardano and xlm and
every other altcoin who doesn't want
that he doesn't want that makes sense so
if if that happens when that pressure
point takes place
then you could pick a number you could
if it goes to five bucks for example if
that happens
that's uh they could sell 10 percent of
the monthly escrow which would give them
500 million dollars they could
settle for 500 million it would be a
huge public win for gary ginsler because
it would be one of the highest
sec settlements as long as it know as
long as they don't classify the token as
a security but but
that settlement won't happen unless they
do basically what was done for ether in
when bill hinman then the director of
corporation finance said you know what
we're going to set aside
the fundraising in the initial years but
today's token is not a security we would
need some kind of declaration from the
sec or the court for that settlement to
happen but to pat's point right now look
that sounds well and good and you know
and for for the record i hold xrp so i
hope it does 5x but right now it's like
75 cents correct so you're not talking
about 250 billion you're talking like 40
billion all right and the us government
has nothing but money in time so from
the outside looking in i'm not an
attorney but this looks frivolous this
looks like somebody's trying to lean on
somebody this looks like maybe i don't
know you know uh like you said moneygram
western union decided to get a couple
senators in there and say you know this
is going to put us completely out of
business like we make 25 we make 25
cents out of every dollar transferred
these guys can do this instantaneously
for no money like get rid of these guys
uh
but
what's to say that they don't just keep
dragging it out dragging it out dragging
it out dragging them out bleeding you
out bleeding you out i mean how long can
they they take this if they take this
thing 10 years
is ripple going to fight for 10 years
what's what's their breaking point
before they say okay you know what fine
where security close the thing down
reincorporated mexico with this same
exact white paper and start over it's a
great question the
my settlement scenario was if
that pressure point existed for ginsler
that it was gonna you know put him on a
business regulating all the other crypto
because of the precedent if those
rulings don't come down favorable for
ripple then i don't think there's a
settlement i think it goes to verdict
and i think it's on appeal and i think
we are looking at a couple years of that
process at some point ripple could tap
out and say listen we'll we'll go with a
certain
designation we can only sell to
accredited investors now you know
there's ways to get around it but i
don't see it happening i i see it either
settling you know
because of those rulings that come down
or
it goes to verdict and there was a
verdict in connecticut not too long ago
where a jury came back where there was a
digital asset a small one
where they uh the jury said that's not
an unregistered security and so
um
that's where i think we're headed
so let me go back to that though let me
go back to that because the point was we
have two things settle
and dismiss right
you almost want settlement more than you
want to be dismissed right because if
they dismiss it
then that means hey we're coming back
again and again and again and again and
again right so there's a part of brad
and chris and the 62 000 and it's 62 000
you're representing but there's more xrp
of course so what's the number 456 i i
saw a number like 450 500 000 xrp
holders something some number like that
right so
so if they if they dismiss
and they don't do anything what happens
then
then we have this cloud
hanging over us and what gerard said i
think you had when you had kurt i was
watching that video when you had kurt on
and and and gerard summed up the
unfortunate nature of what's happened in
this country he literally said
um ripple was similar to bitcoin they
were just dumb enough to do it in the
united states
i mean that sums it up we'll be right
there where there'll be this uncertainty
and right now you have gary gensler
saying come in and talk to us come in
and talk to us as soon as they they're
using those interviews as a way to learn
information about the company as soon as
you leave by time you get to your office
you have a subpoena
brian armstrong of coinbase was trying
to negotiate with them over that lend
product and all of a sudden he shares
with him all that information he goes in
and he talks to him and then what do
they say if you bring that lynn product
we're going to sue you
why do you think they did want to be the
first to to incorporate the united
states they're obviously not dumb guys
why do you think they want they wanted
this fight i feel like i feel like they
kind of maybe not the sec maybe not the
way that they've gone after it but i
feel like they they poked the bear you
know by by
kind of swinging against the current and
i don't know maybe they thought they
would skip the line and be the first
that would become like some sort of
you know state-backed you know uh you
know as eb tucker called it fedcoin
right i don't know what what their what
the intention was i don't know what kind
of conversation you have with them but
but have they ever described to you what
their thinking was with making this you
know an american product no i i've never
i've never spoken to them you know and a
lot of a lot of my critics will say oh
you know he's a plant for ripple look
what he's doing never spoken to him
there was a report done by fox business
on this story and they said deaton's no
fanboy of ripple i don't got anything
against him i'm an xrp holder i want
them to be successful because if they're
successful the whole ecosystem grows but
um but i don't know why a lot of people
ask that question so so so the
definition of security what is the
definition of security all right a
security in the form of an investment
contract that's what's happening here
four things have to happen one has to be
an investment two into a common
enterprise three you were led to believe
hang on investment common enterprise
common enterprise you have to believe a
reasonable expectation of profit okay
and four and you rely on the efforts of
others for that profit if you meet those
four factors and you must meet all four
then it is an investment contract me the
fourth one so so investment common
enterprise
reasonable expectation of profit and
you're relying on others relying on
others
to help make a profit to make the profit
so let me ask you a question yep
this if this is
what the definition of security is i've
been serious seven since
day before 9 11 whatever
2001 i've been serious seven 66 31 26
all those licenses tilted to have my
licenses right yourself you can drink
now
my series seven can drink now you're
right
in one year in one year in a year he can
drink not yet
he would have to drink at a party like
we typically would do but
if that's what you're saying how many
people and and this is a
very simple question how many people buy
xrp ethereum or bitcoin for its
technology rather than as a source of
investment that is a great great
question because there are let me
address this there are a group of people
i represent that
use the technology they go on the ledger
the xrp ledger and they use it as a
bridge asset they buy casino coin
there's a decentralized exchange part of
the uh ledger and they uh trade assets
to trade different currencies it's like
a pseudo-dark web now man and so there
are users of the the technology yeah um
and um
but there's no doubt that there's a lot
of people are speculating right whether
it's bitcoin ethereum i've read it as
much as like 97
that's what i'm saying so so that's the
part where
for them
they don't like that right i mean you
just defined if i ask right now listen
most people are probably not going to
say exactly but if i ask right now why
are you buying bitcoin oh it's a great
investment no no no don't use that word
right you know don't use that word you
know like in in
in as a financial advisor
the what's the one word you cannot use
as an advisor you know like the one word
you have to be careful selling mutual
funds or stocks or bonds what's the word
the g word what's the g word guaranteed
you can't say i do i guarantee you the
stock market with american funds the
last since 1934 when american funds
investment company of after america came
out it's done 12.2 percent dude you can
i guarantee you you can't say that right
so that's the g word so the investment
word you cannot use that with these
technologies okay number one you're
looking at it as an investment common
enterprise reasonable expectation of
profit most people have a reasonable
expectation of profiting
and then relying on somebody else to
make the profit one can say that about
all of them right so then the
conversation becomes decentralized or
centralized
many will say well uh uh you know
bitcoin and ethereum are the most
decentralized uh product out there right
let's just say that's what many will say
right but then they'll say
look uh
ripple is somewhat centralized and
they'll come back and say no it's not
it's pretty decentralized only seven
percent is centralized right
how much uh how much does it matter
whether
the technology or the coin or the wallet
is centralized or decentralized how much
does that matter great question and let
me just point on your your point about
the investment i'm sure that ripple
lawyers and others they don't want me
talking about investments and things
like that so you're 100 right now i will
tell you that you have to focus on the
token versus the technology yes the
network versus the token ripple i will
tell you right now i i can absolutely
win any argument that the xrp ledger is
more decentralized than the ethereum
network i put every dollar i got it
first of all because
if ripple
went away they filed bankruptcy tomorrow
right
xrp ledger continues xrp continues
vitalik buterin dies
you're going to tell me ethereum's going
to continue to go mark cuban just
recently said when he was challenged by
bitcoin max he's on a on a clubhouse i
was listening in and they were like
saying to mark they were like look
it's not even ether 2.0 they're going
from proof of work to proof of stake
you know they keep promising promising
promising to never deliver and mark says
i think that uh vitalik's going to
figure it out and i'm putting my money
on that that's centralization right
right there now the problem for ripple
interesting is that they own 50
of the xrp
okay that's token centralization that's
token centralization and that's the real
problem for them and a lot of people
look at that and say well you own half
of the token that's the market
manipulation people were talking about
they're worried about that and that's
why brad garden house came up with the
escrow where they put it all in escrow
and each month only a billion of the 50
billion will come out and then they'll
go back in escrow and they can't touch
that's good he did that by the way very
very good he did that very smart you
made a great point too about about
vitalik like i'm a big ethereum guy
anybody that's been listening to podcast
knows i'm very very very bullish on
ethereum but i'm bullish on ethereum
because of italic same way that i i own
tesla because of elon musk elon musk
bails on tesla i'm out right you know so
the
the you know proponent of the great man
theory that's a great great point that
you're making man but when it comes to
you know as an attorney right when
you're looking at what the sec is doing
and pat made a great point about okay
like we can't set this up as an
investment well then i can see you know
i'm just a dummy from jersey and i can
see a kafka trap from a mile away okay
well if it's not that
if it's not an investment then it's
gambling and you still need to register
with the gaming commission because
you're buying a token on its lottery
essentially you're buying this thinking
that it could go up but with uh you know
no no fail safe if it goes down either
way they're going to want you to
register you either you're either
gambling or you're investing and they've
kind of got you trapped john i just want
to give you a full disclaimer very few
dummies from new jersey used the word
kafka trap two seconds after saying new
jersey
[Laughter]
i didn't listen to the rest of what he
said after he said that word i'm like
what the hell does that mean
so basically man you you see them
they're trying to corner the token into
regulation yeah first they're going to
go after it as an investment property
right and then you're going to say it's
not an investment property like pat's
saying it's not an investment property
they're going to be like okay well what
what makes it not an investment property
well it it it could bottom out it could
hollow out oh so then you're gambling
right now you need to register his
lottery now you need to register as as
gaming
they're letting your arguments you're
going to win this argument and through
winning this argument give them their
next argument if i learned anything from
doing mafia states of america with the
questions pat asked rudy the government
is taking their losses and turning them
into their next wins right they will
change the law until they have you so
what my concern is with something like
this especially with the settlement
because the settlement makes too much
sense just make it go away the
settlement gets you closer to the
regulation
if it's not going to be this
then they're going to get you the next
time and it's not going to be registered
as a security it's going to be
registered as gaming it's going to have
to be registered to some sort of
gambling you're going to have to be 21
and older to buy it you're going to have
to buy it with certain restrictions like
that's they're going to regulate it some
way or another and we're trying the
whole point of this is the
decentralization and deregulation the
whole point of this is to be outside of
their scope of control so you know that
that's kind of like now that's not your
concern obviously because your concern
is to win the lawsuit in hand but
you know and again i didn't know that
you didn't know the guys of ripple but
i'm wondering if they are then saying
would they rather be a security than be
gaming than be seen as some sort of uh
lottery essence because like you said
there's the technology but then there's
the speculation right and the
speculation right now 97 of the people
don't even know what they're doing
that's that is gambling that's lottery
well one problem in the united states is
that you have so many multiple agencies
it's already regulated
xrp and ripple were registered well
ripple was registered as a money
transmitter and they had they got sued
by the government department of justice
in finson and they had a settlement in
2015 and they paid 700 000 dollars and
and they were told you have to register
all your sales of xrp through fencing
and that happened in 2015 and then of
course five and a half years later the
sec comes down and says oh by the way
uh it's also a security right and so
what we really need is congress to step
in
and and and authorize the right agency
to govern cryptocurrencies these are
securities then what's an nft
if the token is a security what's an nft
it
what pat went over
you can imagine many things fit those if
you want
no question about it non-fungible by the
way this is this is why i'm concerned
absolutely this is why i'm concerned
because look joseph kennedy who is he
he's a bootlegger he's the father of the
kennedy it's amazing there hasn't been a
movie made about joking there has to be
i mean
he's a legend okay the kid the guy would
sit down his kids
uh in suits and say which one are you
guys going to be a president first can
you imagine like setting that
expectation
for the ira i think you got your next
project
[Laughter]
so
so i've interviewed rfk rfq is a very
good friend i think we have something
coming up together debate that we're
doing uh uh part two with his book that
just came out with his best friend in
regards to his best friend anthony fauci
he loves anthony fauci uh uh that's a
joke by the way
so
so joseph kennedy before there's any sec
anything going on the guy just knew pump
and dumb pump and dumb pump and dumb
pump and dump everybody and their
mothers was doing it right
and then security exchange act of 1933
and such an investment company act of
1934 and all these other stuff you know
whatever these years these things
started coming out right
right after the great depression was it
a good thing was it a bad thing many
will say was a good thing because guys
during that time capitalized because
there was no regulation
they came in they took money out and you
know the rich got richer and a lot of
people got crushed that couldn't afford
to lose that three thousand dollars or
forty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars or that the
girl you're talking about whose father
passed away in insurance policy paid 75
000 and she put the 75 000 in xrp and
she can't take the money out and that 75
000 is now
whatever 20 000 but she needs that money
she can't touch that money right okay
so
the other part is what draper said tim
draper i don't know if you saw the tim
draper interview with gary uh uh three
years ago in 2018 when this interview
took place and draper gave a system i
love what he said and by the way for
people that don't know who tim draper is
tim draper is a beast of a guy is who he
is here's how he broke down the system
he says
bankers are panicking he said this in 18
he says this is their system it's always
been their system step number one they
say this is nothing cryptocurrency
bitcoin nft nothing you ain't got to
worry about it there is no way they can
you know compete with somebody like us
where jamie dimon's got seven trillion
dollars of money circulating through
chase on a daily basis that's like
whatever the number they say that's a
pretty big number that they go through
right so he says step number one
these guys are nothing they're not going
to make it it's just a fad it's going to
go away step number two now it's too big
where you have to face it okay so what
they do is three bankers all get
together and say we can't make this
happen what do we do step number four is
we sue them step number five is we bring
our government friends to say i need a
favor i need you to sue those guys and
he's telling this to gary when gary
wasn't yet the sec chair he was only the
chair of the cft uh uh
commodities uh futures uh trade
commission right
he's clairvoyant
exactly that's what was so epic about i
don't know if you've seen this or not
what did gary say powerful so then
gary's trying well well but but but i
think we're already there but i think
we're already there and then he says and
the last one is tim draper freaking mike
drop he says make or buy this is what
everybody do all the great companies
they either make or buy he says you
either have to choose to make a similar
product similar exchange similar token
similar wallet or you have to buy it and
that's eventually going to happen so
that's where we are today now go to
politics and bring politics on board
for four years i've been saying when
people say bitcoin ethereum ripple you
know all these crypto patrick that's
what i said you have to realize
there are those who are driven by
freedom leave me alone let me do
something better and there are those
that can't stand it that you keep
getting richer and more powerful they
cannot stand that you keep making money
we had matt zeller on yesterday and we
talked about the trump and i hate trump
i hate trump you know how angry he got
in and you and i had lunch at louis
bossie i like matt zeller yeah oh i do
too yeah we're bringing him back on
board i think matt's great yeah but uh
uh you and i talked about it during
lunch and you said what you said why do
you think it's such a thing about he
broke him yeah what was it there's
something about trump that makes these
people and i said i silently angry i
said because
there are certain people in life you're
okay losing to you're kind of like well
listen i lost my cousin
the guy kind of comes from the richest
family and he went to harvard i'm okay
if i lose to that guy makes more money
than he's more successful it's fine
but then you have that one cousin whose
mom and dad were let's just say you know
divorce and one was an alcoholic one
went to jail
that cousin beats your ass in life you
can't deal with that you got to diminish
them you got to throw them you got to do
all this other stuff right
krypto is almost like that cousin in
that coin where it's like listen fiat's
been around for a while gold's been
around for a while who the hell you
think
you are
there are a lot of people that don't
want to see this happening but there's
one good thing that's happening today to
the crypto community
there's more true believers today than
ever before
there are more credible sources that are
coming and saying look we're putting our
money into it we're going to fight as
well it's now the crypto community is a
political party yep so we're back in the
days where democrats wanted to win the
black vote and they didn't have to bury
goldwater that's a great point and when
they
the democrats wanted to win the black
vote because blacks forever have been
conservatives i mean martin luther king
was a conservative he was a republican
we got to win it barry goldwater gave it
away went from 60 to 92
african-americans voted for who for
democrats and they've had it since then
92 80 civil rights it's been a while
right yep
political parties today have to be very
careful and i think this is going to
favor whoever is on the free enterprise
side of the political side because
gary's a democrat
biden's a democrat kamala's a democrat
and the ones that are going after crypto
are all on one side of the political
party
the libertarians the independents which
is the crypto community crypto committee
is not republicans they're typically
independents and libertarians
anti-establishment which republican is
establishment to them so is the
democratic party
but i think what's happening right now
is if if this happens
i don't think this is just a financial
issue for them if they settle the you
know what whatever they do forget about
that part i think they're gonna be
crushed politically because it's no
longer just a hundred thousand votes or
half a million votes you've got millions
on top of millions that now have
influence i'll tell you why you're 100
right especially with the younger
community all right uh this is again eb
tucker great great guy we had on last
week
you know there's kids that i've coached
in baseball kids that that i still
follow that are now young adults they've
never held gold they don't give a
about gold but they've been trading
crypto for five years absolutely they've
gone and they they're they're learning
blockchain technology in schools i
learned cursive like you know what i'm
saying these kids are learning
blockchain triple ledger they understand
the technology in ways that we don't you
know we're almost old in this and these
guys this is this is not like new alien
technology to the next generation this
is just a way of life to the next
generation so it's only going to get
bigger and they saw what government does
they saw what with with gme what
happened with gme when the government
literally stepped in and made it okay
for the hedge fund not to go under for
people that don't remember what happened
with gme they overhedged on a short wall
street bets came out a couple ant you
know rogue analysts came out and said
you know these guys are leveraged past
their teeth all you got to do is keep
the keep the price above the put and
they got to pay whatever it could go up
to a million a share theoretically and
it had gotten up it was a six dollar
share it had gotten up over three
hundred and fifty dollars and it was
going to go up over a thousand and they
just turned it off you could sell the
stock right but you couldn't buy it no
you're right right so the
what the sec did in that regard or what
they didn't do i think i ended up
getting like a class action like 12
check from robin hood or something like
that we built all these exchanges
if you didn't believe
in the net and the necessity for a
decentralized unregulated blockchain
like yeah you can lose your money on
mount gox but you can also lose your
money in the stock market and they can
steal from you and they'll you have no
recourse whatsoever
that right there
that what happened with that wall street
bets what happened with that 6 million
you know i think it's up to 10 million
reddit uh
a subreddit
is you had an entire block worldwide
that lost trust and faith in the market
and in regulation whatever little faith
that they had in regulation they lost it
all overnight let me tell you how on
point you are just a little over a month
ago i i started a website and i'm
plugging it but i don't make any money
there's no sponsors it's called
cryptolaw.us
and i i put an app in it and all you do
is you put in your address and your zip
code and you type your message and it
goes to your congress office
and your two senators
in a little over a month
messages have been sent to
these elected officials 100 senators
have been contacted by these crypto
people
and 420 representatives all right it's
making a difference they are very
engaged all right that's an incredible
number that happens six thousand dollars
that doesn't do anything trust me when i
tell you haven't been in government that
does everything so many people don't
make contact with their elected
officials that the few people that do
their voices amplified so much i tell i
tell a story from when i i think one of
the first times i was on the podcast it
was an old lady and none and she thought
people were speeding too fast down the
church and she would literally call and
show up at the state house once a week
hey we need a speed we need a speed bump
is is there any way we can get a speed
bump i'll raise money for a speed bump
and then finally it got to a point where
it was like we need to fast track the
speed bump i don't want to deal with
this lady anymore she was the nicest
activist in history the lady got her
speed bump it took her like four months
right it was just one person
that writing an email making a phone
call showing up the state house and she
got her speed bump yeah you know like
the system works if you're the squeaky
wheel gets the oil and that
cryptolaw.com that's a game changer and
i'm actually wrong it's 8 000. i just
remember it's over 8 000 messages have
been sent to them and
people are sending me some of their
letters and some of them many of them
get the form letter hey thank you for
contact don't do that don't do the
formula right some have been doing that
i'm talking about
the sec i mean not the sec the elected
representatives they're getting
from the app but some of them are
actually meeting with their constituents
and learning because they see where this
is going i've had people send me letters
that they received from their
congressmen a couple of them here in
florida where they said we're gonna uh
we're we're involved in this sec we're
monitoring a thousand people bro eight
thousand people look at jersey you just
had phil murphy win by what six thousand
votes yeah you think guys listen 8 000
people he's like if they're going to
write me an email they're going to vote
let me tell you let me tell you if i'm
if i'm if i'm the democratic party right
no the republican party
or if i've ever like the rem
libertarian party that puts a candidate
like george jorgensen love her
philosophies
love the philosophies you can't sell
you're not a salesperson right people
thought spike cohen was running if they
if there ever was a time that you
saw an opportunity for ross pearl was
able to get to 21 whatever whatever the
number was 19 to 21
as an independent
if you've ever wanted to capitalize on a
public if today libertarian independent
party wanted to get to 30 35
like this is a market this is not going
away but here's here's a concern that i
got for you i'm going to go back to
so ponzi scheme you know the word ponzi
came about this was this guy there was a
guy named ponzi okay so
what's the whole thing about a ponzi
scheme and a pyramid scheme you hear
these words ponzi scheme pyramid
everything nowadays called a pyramid
scheme everything nowadays is called a
ponzi scheme it's very easy people drop
that word regularly right
nft is being called that you know
cryptocurrency has been called that a
lot of things i've called the
a multi-level marketing has been called
pyramid scheme uh ponzi scheme but the
challenge where some people win
is when there's not an actual usage of
the product
let me say that one more time there's
not an actual usage
of the product meaning the product they
sell is not being used
if i'm anybody right now i want to get
to the 60
number 70 number which means something
there's got to be 70 percent of the
people that buy this coin
use the technology use other aspects of
it rather than just
a uh
yeah so for example hypothetically
more
all these guys that are pro bitcoin pro
ethereum pro you know whatever doge you
know you just saw elon musk yesterday
said we're not going to be taking
payment for what through doge right
because he says uh the technology is
better than x y even though this started
as a meme thing it's better than all the
other guys with their technology yeah
elon musk is doing the right thing
what elon musk is doing is he's making
it he's giving it credibility so for
example
insurance companies need to start
accepting bitcoin as a payment like when
you talked about the whole i trust
capital which is the ira that's great
small businesses need to start more
taking bitcoin as a payment ethereum has
a payment
more of these folks that are pro crypt
of the future which is that's the
direction you're going decentralized the
bank can no longer bully you and do all
the other stuff power can no longer
control your life any of those things
great
but there needs to be a major push into
the usage of the technology rather than
the investment
if they went there i think
you you're a hundred percent on and
that's why i brought up the utility
listen i can make a very good argument
that xrp
is being utilized way more than bitcoin
or ethereum as it relates to just that
token being usage cross-border payments
uh people get on the ledger they send
money you
there's a an app a
developer independent of ripple called
spin the bits and it's spinning bitcoin
where he uses the xrp ledger as a layer
2 solution to the bitcoin network
problem right it takes 10 minutes at the
low end for bitcoin to an hour for the
transaction to go on the ledger
instantaneously ripples xrp is
instantaneous three to five seconds and
you know when you had kurt on here and
he said you know bitcoin uh is um is
like seven transactions btc on and
is 15
ripple xrp
the token 1300 per second transactions
and fraction of a penny i can move i've
watched it i can move 2 million dollars
worth of bitcoin
for a fraction of a penny using the xrp
ledger as you said earlier the
technology is awesome
it's absolutely in my opinion the
superior tech as far as the network uh
and i think when you get to usage xrp is
ahead of the game uh that's that's where
you win you win you win there that's my
opinion i may be wrong but i think you
win
by me needing to use the product if i
use the product it validates that it's
not just an investment here's the
problem though guys right and this is
the beauty of decentralization and this
is also you know this is where just
decentralization lags behind
who's the patrick bet david of of ripple
who's moving the company forward and
from a marketing perspective who's out
there creating the infrastructure
necessary who's got the user interface
so that everybody can get on their phone
and within you know three seconds learn
how to use the product and use all these
different ledgers that we're talking
about who's going to teach my mother how
to use ripple on a day to day it was
impossible to teach her how to use venmo
it took like two years to get her to get
her on venmo you know what i'm saying so
that that's that becomes the issue with
with cryptos going forward
who which community can come together
and coagulate in in a common direction
that there's going they're going to have
the bitcoin atms and somebody's going to
have the conversations with you know a
mutual of omaha and say you should be
using you know bitcoin to to take
payments like who's who's out there
actively selling who's out there
actively marketing who's out there
actively creating infrastructure and
these usage things there's a trillion
dollar industry trillion dollar industry
in the future for people that i mean
think about it think about the very
first person who allows
easypass to have bitcoin and takes
you know one tenth of a cent of a
transaction for every easy pass that
goes through every toll in the country
right that they're they're they're
they're worth a trillion dollars no
you're right so i mean like but who
who's doing that i mean right now like
what who is who is pushing that
technology forward who's the driving
force behind that technology in these in
these because these aren't like
companies they're like
organizations they're they're they're
you know it's the beauty of it it's the
wild wild west right well that's there's
no directive well two things you'd be a
great securities lawyer d because do you
know consumptive use defeats the whole
case for for xrp or ether gets sued the
sec in the complaint they have an entire
section that tries to say there is no
consumptive use it is all mere
speculation there are no users of the
network so you're 100 on point and the
problem the danger why this case is so
dangerous is what you just said who's
out there promoting it because once you
are a promoter
are you a common enterprise
are you leading people to a reasonable
expectation of profit based on your
efforts
you know if if somebody was a drug
dealer that started it is it now a rico
case are you now complicit in
international smuggling like if you buy
like
this this stuff's the wild west man nfts
like i saw
and and you as a lawyer i'm sure you've
heard this as well
there are people out there right now
right that are creating an nft for 300
ethereum okay they've got a million
dollars in ethereum sitting in the bank
they buy their own nft for a million
dollars ethereum they spent a million
dollars but now they have the nft and
the million dollars ethereum right they
sell it at a loss crazy for half a
million dollars so they lost on the
ledger a half million dollars they took
a half million dollar loss but they got
a million and a half etherium right you
can do that over and over and over it's
not illegal right now right
you get you're getting a half million
dollar loss and you're increasing your
wealth
is that what what's going on with the
nfts i mean is that the idea here think
about think about it from this
standpoint okay
what allows the government to want to
tighten up regulation on guns what what
allows it like think about what helps
their argument public perception no
forget public perception it's dummies
who
do stupid things that are irresponsible
with a gun then the politician comes out
and says what i told you i'll say it we
we have to you know and you know what my
governor knew some i'm gonna do exactly
what texas did to abortion we're going
to do to guns in california here's what
we're going to do moving forward you can
no longer buy
right so
meaning where i'm going with this is the
following
the the quick money get rich quick
scheme type of guys are unfortunately
unfortunately
making life
difficult for the rest of the guys that
are doing it the right way the long-term
play-wise and this has been going on for
a while
government the the regulators they they
they they love
that that one percent of the con men
that are you know that are trying to
they say you see
you see that's exactly why we need to
protect you might be there i'm that
person it might be them they're the ones
going around breaking the windows
gary ginsler just did that
just a couple weeks ago when he brought
up bitcoin someone brought up bitcoin he
goes it's being used for ransomware do
you know what percentage
that that really is being used to play
but that's the best that's the play and
you know like for example i uh
last year we had a couple hundred
thousand dollars of fake valuetainment
consulting uh bitcoin stolen and we get
the calls and i get on the phone with
these guys like listen that's not us
right that's not us look at the email
you got that's from
davidcryptospecialty
at
gmail.com i said that's not us buddy we
don't have that website that's not our
website let's go look at the ip address
oh i feel so bad my wife is so
upset at me so so there is that going on
as well absolutely so there's got to be
a part on you know
a a a society has to either accept the
fact that if that happens to you you
were the one that didn't verify the
source that was coming your way so you
deserve exactly what you got right or
a society needs to say no we need to
figure out a way to eliminate 100 of
that and that's when these government
people come in and they feel special
that they're needed to do their job and
then they go
turn one small regulation into 78
different regulations and then another
guy comes in try deregulating stuff so
my concern is
they're going to point to these guys and
say this is why you need our help what
would you what would you which would you
prefer in that spectrum you know which
one i would prefer uh to me i would
prefer
uh look the whole concept of
valuetainment is what education that's
the whole concept of valuetainment look
here's what to look out for here's where
to be paranoid about when you're raising
money keep these things in mind before
you raise money ask these 10 questions
before you're hiring somebody ask them
these five questions before you open up
an office and sign a lease
know what the commercial real estate guy
makes here's what their motive is
understand yeah so so to me i'm all
about educate educate educate educate
educate and then look if you screw up
it's on you i've screwed up god knows
how much money i've lost grown up that's
organic regulation and that's organic
regulation part of that that's got to be
organic regulation but there are those
who abuse others
my punishment for abuse would go higher
my punishment to to want to hurt
somebody's livelihood and their savings
if you do that
i uh it wouldn't sit very well with less
laws but harsher consequences less laws
harsher consequences my approach is what
it would be the problem we have though
is it's always an extreme it's either
no regulation or it's a nanny state
you know and that's the problem it's
it's the financial crisis after it came
down and dodd-frank was passed and all
that
i couldn't get a mortgage to my home and
i just wanted a home equity loan even
though i had the home was worth
two-thirds what i'm asking for and i had
five times that in a savings account but
they said because one year
i fell under a certain threshold at my
law firm you know settlements were
delayed or whatnot
they're doing the exact same thing now
with covet they're doing the exact same
thing now they're telling people that
they had a lapse of income they were
like yeah right
the world was shut down right but but
before that anyone there was no
verification income loans it was no uh
no job falsification all those things
predatory lending so but the problem we
have right now is when a situation like
this case happens in certain government
officials
start picking the winners and losers
and that's what's happened in this
particular case and i hope we have time
to go over some of those comments go
ahead all right so i just want to share
with you a couple minutes and interject
go ahead right so clayton gets appointed
immediately he is called clayton is
former sec champion thank you former sec
chair jay clayton immediately he's
described by rolling stone magazine as
the most conflicted sec chairman in the
history of the united states because of
his connection to the banks and the wall
street's
as confirmation hearing him and
elizabeth warren go back he agrees that
he should recuse himself that he should
never
vote
against one of his clients having an
enforcement action like he has to step
back right so that goes on he gets his
good friend
william hinman to become the director of
corporation of finance
these guys are heavily connected they
were the the main sponsors of alibaba
ipo and many other types of ipos bill
hinman comes in jay clayton is from firm
sullivan and cromwell okay and bill
hinman is from simpson thatcher
well
immediately in december of 2017
sullivan and cromwell represents the
co-founder of ethereum joe lubin and
consensus and bill hinman has a meeting
with him and they start talking
immediately the very next day
consensus general counsel gets up and
starts talking about how they're
building this alliance with the sec
they go on to have four to five more
meetings with consensus and the
co-founders of ether with bill hinman
bill hinman's firm
so just so i can track it so you have a
private law firm the ethereum and then
you have the sec all together in
meetings right what you have is you have
the co-founder of ethereum joe lubin and
the founder of consensus meeting with
sec
bill hinman and his firm is a member of
the enterprise ethereum alliance to what
end what in what capacity what was the
what was the reasoning for the meeting i
think he's getting to it
the reason for the media is because they
start lobbying for a ethereum free pass
right they want to say hey ethereum yeah
we maybe did an ico because it was the
world's first ico but it's to
sufficiently decentralize so jay clayton
then
tells andreessen horowitz which is a
huge investor in crypto right they have
the 2.2 billion fund big ether backers
he says write a memo up for us and tell
us what you want they write a memo and a
safe harbor proposal there are multiple
meetings that take place a secret
meeting in march
of 28th of 2018
and it gets leaked because there's some
stuff going on in there and they propose
a safe harbor for crypto but the only
crypto they mention is ether and then
what happens on june 14th
bill hinman gratuitously as director of
corporation and finance
very high up at the sec gives his
infamous speech where he says setting
aside the fundraising that took place
with ether
it is sufficiently decentralized today
and therefore current cells of ethereum
are no longer considered a security
he goes on cnbc
and he says well you know when we look
at ethereum we don't see a third party
promoter
you just had a meeting with him it's a
back room deal you just had meetings
with him he had a meeting on june 8th
six days before the speech he had a
meeting with the promoter so he gets up
there and says we don't see it criminal
law this sounds like a proper meeting
almost and then absolutely then all the
people started asking what about xrp xrp
was actually number two at the time
behind bitcoin and it was battling ether
for the number two spot oh we're not
going to comment on any further tokens
joe lubin then goes out and starts
basically saying what the sec is going
to do he says we're working with the sec
they gave ether a pass they gave bitcoin
a pass all these other coins he
literally says this are
are
absolute spectacularly disadvantaged
compared to ether they didn't mention
xrp that's very interesting he says the
sec is going to be coming after certain
projects all of this takes place right
in the meantime
bill hinman is collecting 15 million
dollars from his law firm while he's at
the sec
which is a member of the enterprise
ethereum alliance right sullivan and
comrel which represents jay clayton's
farm that's his farm
they represent consensus
and the co-founder of ethereum wow right
all of that's going down now listen to
this
just before the lawsuit happens now in
the meantime in the meantime ripple's
allowed to buy nine percent of moneygram
and use xrp it's actually they're giving
it to moneygram who's then selling it on
exchanges for dollars
they uh they coinbase in january of 2019
goes to
the sec and says look our securities
lawyers
have decided that xrp is not a security
we want to list it what do you say sec
sec doesn't say anything
one month later xrp is listed on
coinbase
then
in october
one river
comes out and they make a 1 billion bet
on bitcoin and ethereum that's in
october
it also
consensus decides that they're going to
buy quorum which is
a competitor to ripple they're trying to
replace swift the messaging and money uh
banking system basically which is what
ripple was in completely focused on and
then on the last day
you've got on a three to two vote who
does clayton go with he goes with the
two democrats even though he's a
republican votes to file the suit
against ripple as he's walking out the
door
his excuse has been reported well he
deferred to the staff
the director of enforcement leaves three
weeks later
to go to simpson and thatcher
clayton left
bill hinman left all of these senior
people
who were supposed to foresee this case
right and see it through all leave
two weeks before
what i mentioned earlier before this
happens joseph grundfest former sec
commissioner who helped ethereum
writes and i got the letter here writes
to clayton and the commissioners and
says listen
you've never made a material distinction
between ether and xrp
if xrp's a security ether is a security
if you're going to allow xrp ether to be
traded you got to let
them trade he even goes as far as 15
million reasons why that's not true he
goes as far as to say if you file this
lawsuit
it caused him to question the
commission's discretion this is like a
damn john grisham right man he says that
and so what happens jay clayton votes
for the lawsuit
the two democrats vote for it
the lawsuit's filed they all leave jay
clayton goes to one river
bitcoin and ether
and guess what the people that helped
write the hinman speech and by the way
these are all facts on cryptology we
have a video library of all these
interviews dangerously close to making
an allegation here all right and and i
will tell you they basically um
come out and and bill hinman now works
he's a partner
with the ether investors who helped
write the speech that gave ether a free
pass and and that's not an allegation
that's facts because lawyers who are
part of the meeting have come out and
said
i didn't think ether was sufficiently
decentralized but bill hinman did i'm
not sure why he did
15 million reasons might tell you why
being a partner at a 2.2 billion so
here's the thing about allegation i'm
not saying
that they broke a law but what i'm
saying tell me there's not enough for an
independent investigation
that's all we want we want an
independent investigation in the
meantime don't take john deaton's word
for it an independent organization in
power
is in litigation with the scc because
they won't turn over documents they
won't give us bill hinman's calendar how
is a guy who's being paid by tax dollars
director of corporation finance
they won't give us his calendars to who
he met when he met they won't release it
the this independent organization that
sued the sec asked for any ethics
discussions between bill between clayton
and the sec about his post-employment
hinman
they say there's no documents or they
won't give the documents the freedom of
information act they won't give it yeah
right this is
75 years 75 years now for the freedom of
information right
so that's all in litigation but that's
what's going on you know what i mean and
so what i'm doing is saying listen you
want to go after ripple go after ripple
go after brad garland house i don't care
but
you are destroying people's lives
by attacking the token itself and why
did you allow the money grant to happen
why did you allow coinbase
to do it how how how does coinbase go in
there and say we're going to list xrp
unless you tell us otherwise
and then they don't and they list it and
then eighteen months later as he's
walking out the door he slaps a lot told
no yet
right but it's what i'm saying and so
let me ask you who hates if you were to
make a list of people who hate xrp who
would you say hate xrp not not dislike
who hated joe lubin who is the
co-founder of ethereum the founder of
consensus we have him on video saying
xrp is overvalued xrp's a coin
xrp this xrp is not a competitor and so
we're not worried about it the day of
the hinman's speech where he gave ether
the free pass
joe lubin goes on the same stage
right after bill hinman and he says
these words he says oh by the way i
didn't get to read all of the the speech
did they bring up xrp
and the moderator goes no he goes well
isn't that interesting
right
he goes on later in interviews to say
that the sec is going to be coming after
certain projects and any hints that it's
going to be
xrp
and and the thing that
that you have to understand is the guy
who's saying xrp is not a competitor xrp
is not a competitor why is it the first
token you bring up after you're given
the free pass and the other thing that
the sec won't give us is did you know
that 63 emails went out
with that draft speech that gave aether
a free pass
do you know who was the only
commissioner to get a draft version of
it was that jay clayton did you know
crypto mom herself hester purse never
saw it
how do you draft why would clayton even
be involved in that that draft like why
would he even
he gave input he's the only commissioner
bill hinman was deposed ripple was
successful in getting him deposed of
course they redact everything to the
public
and uh i have it here if you want to see
it they the lawyers ask them did you
ever represent how much is redacted
can i see
this is this goes to pat you were
telling the story a couple weeks back
about now this is you were at harvard
and you you said that there was a guy
who was having trouble he said just find
a congressman pay him a half a million
he's going through an election and he'll
help you put up a lot to hurt them this
is it yeah
he's asked questions like have you ever
worked for ethereum foundation look at
the answers look at the freaking
look at the redactions all right and
this isn't the whole this is look at
this this isn't the whole
awesome dude are you kidding me
right this is it
now now
why would they redact pat
if he's asked a question
have you ever had clients that are part
of the ethereum foundation if i
represent you and your business yeah i
can't talk about what we talk about but
if it's some record
no it was an exhibit that's that's
probably right can we show this oh yeah
yes you can show it so like absolutely
so i don't know if people can see this
but this is ages of that this is an
entire page of every single word on the
page redacted and there's
there's
there's pages of it
this is your this is your transparent
security exchange commission holy moly
you were going somewhere you were going
somewhere about this uh why they would
do this
well what i'm saying is it's not even
privileged there's no reason to redact
it someone could ask me are you the
lawyer for pat
i say sure i'm not going to tell you
what we talk about but it's not i can't
say
you know what i mean these firms
brag if you go on his firm simpson
thatcher they'll brag we represent
google we represent yahoo we were part
of the alibaba ipo they brag about who
their clients are but in a deposition of
taxpayer dollars we can't get to know
what you're talking about we fired up
man i got because what do you do
what do you do as a citizen
you're trying to live your life you're
trying to play by the rules they're
they're setting the rules you're trying
to play by the rules and then they come
and whenever they want they change them
and then you get no recourse the way you
feel right now is the way i felt on
christmas eve this time last year i felt
just like that and that's why i filed
the lawsuit it's a helpless infuriating
feeling man this is the type of
that makes you want to get the um but
here's a here's a question for you
um
so
you so
the bigger names that are supporters of
ethereum it's not small names no these
are big names big right uh the big uh
hedge funds that are bullish on
uh ethereum these are not small names
these are very very well-known names
right that you're talking about fortress
arc investment group uh brevin
renaissance tech there's some of these
bigger names billions yeah billions so
which means they have access
to uh uh
they are banking on them being it so is
this
a situation where ethereum um
doesn't want an x rp and it's a form of
wanting to eliminate competition is that
all it is or it's a form of let's get
rid of these guys and let's not put the
attention on us let's get the attention
to xrp is that kind of what this is sure
i think joe lubin said it best i said
when he said that every altcoin
is
is spectacularly disadvantaged when
compared to ethereum he said bitcoin and
ether we've been blessed we have the
regulatory past we have the free pass
these other folks don't yeah and and
look at how much activity went to
ethereum since that speech in 2018
what half of nft's learning theory
just came out right i'm looking at this
article ethereum joe lubin defense sccm
at ripple lawsuit
uh as the sec is facing a barrage of
criticism for its uh
scattershot approach to regulatory
cryptocurrencies the much feared
regulatory agency as a supporter within
the industry consensus ceo
joe lubin and in a recent interview with
the information lubin who is known as
one ethereum co-founders claims that the
sec chair gary
demands for greater authority in
regulating cryptos are justified the
head of ethereum development studio says
that the agency has a lot of legit
arguments
may have legit arguments in the cases
that are being discussed right now while
ripple the company that was sued by cc
in december over its unregistered
security sales
accuses the agency of stifling
innovation in the u.s lubin does not
think that is the case i don't believe
the sec is trying to squelch innovation
and he continues
making other comments about a ripple's
admin that xrp was treated on fairly by
the sec a speech by william henman the
sec's former top official in which he
said that ether was not an unregistered
security became a breeding ground for
conspiracy theories about potential
interests within the xrp community some
are convinced that hinman had skin in
the game merely because of his ties to
simpson thatcher law firm which is
member of the enterprise ethereum
alliance yet the sec made it clear that
it has not taken an official position on
its regulatory status and hinman was
only expressing his personal opinion
ripple theobrad is careful about his
words choice steering clear of peddling
free pass conspiracy theories in a
recent interview however he said that
the timing of the lawsuit was suspicious
so now why is uh everybody likes
dogecoin what is brad's issue with
dogecoin
you know i don't know other than i think
it comes down to the utility argument
that you brought up where you said
elon's being smart elon knows exactly
what you said right so he's going to get
you know him and mark cuban who's also
into doge they're they're selling their
merchandise dallas maverick merchandise
tesla merchandise and they're using
smart they're using doze as a means of
payment yeah and so it's going to drive
it up and
and he's right the the the reality is
dogecoin as a means of payment
transaction is better than bitcoin on
the network there's no doubt about it
you know bitcoin right now it's digital
gold it's a store of value and that's
why you should buy it that's the use
case for bitcoin you know ethereum it's
the smart contracts and they're the 2.0
eventually and all that's going to
happen that's their story with ripple it
is these superior payment transactions
you can
literally send there's a guy named
michael arrington and he moved 50
million dollars
um
into his uh
uh
balance sheet and it cost him thirty
dollars well that that's
that was the argument that i had heard
against xrp was the the drug trafficking
argument like okay you can uh you can
buy
two million dollars of cocaine and have
it in uh you know colombia for 30 bucks
in in 10 minutes and that's you know so
it's gonna it's gonna make the the drug
trafficking uh international drug
trafficking and all smuggling you know
that that much easier and i'm saying
like well they're doing it anyway well
it's also it's also listen
it's all fought about the criminal stuff
because it's a public ledger the cia and
the fbi have come out and said that they
basically hope that terrorism used the
distributed ledger you can find them
it's an open legend
as well said that as well he said that
this is better for the fbi because now
they can catch the bad guy better
i don't know if that's true or not but
that's what he said pat they're full of
anyway man because look they got a
problem with the technology that could
do this but then the president's son is
selling a painting for two million
dollars like okay and then we're just
supposed to be beautiful
well i mean this guy is incredible like
i'd rather have the laptop shame on you
for discrediting
how dare i yeah i mean yeah it's uh he's
a real uh he's a real crack uh artist
with the paintbrush but i i can't speak
for brad i just think it comes down to
that utility argument i'll read the
article to you on why he said that so
here's the article that just came out on
why he has an issue i think it's on page
five let me see here uh uh on the bottom
okay here we go bitcoin news uh deutsche
coin is loved by all except brad garland
house dogecoin is arguably one of the
world's most popular most successful
cryptocurrencies in the world starting
out as a joke roughly eight years ago
and the currency has been established as
one of the most leading digital assets
of today as a marquee capital brown uh
uh more than a billion dollars and has
garnered attention from elon man mark
you and clearly it's popular coin and
everyone seems to like it except brad
garland cows the ceo ripple in recent
interviews stated that the asset was not
good in the long run when it came to
expansion of the crypto space he
mentioned i'm actually not convinced
somewhat controversially i guess that
dogecoin is good for the crypto market
dogecoin has some inflationary uh
dynamics itself that wouldn't make it
reluctant to hold it's interesting that
these words are coming from brad whose
coin xrp was ultimately out done by
dogecoin at one point doge eventually
rose so high early this year that it
became world's fourth largest
cryptocurrency by the market and beat
out xrp now uh though now things have
calmed down a bit pushing doge to the
side garland cal stated that the still
feels bitcoin holds the top position in
crypto when it came down to crypto uh
currency serving as an inflationary
hedge tool he commented when people are
concerned about holding a fiat currency
that might be inflating and that's
devaluing they're looking at how can i
hold other assets that won't have that
same inflationary dynamic is managing
with dogecoin is that currency does not
employ inflationary barricades the way
bitcoin does as of now doge has
approximately 132 billion units
outstanding while an additional 5
million new coins enter circulation
every year
so i guess that's the reason why he has
an issue with them in regards to
inflationary barricades well xrp is you
know it has a hundred billion it's not
going to get any more sort of a similar
argument to bitcoin instead of 21
million it's 100 billion
and uh
but at the same time you know everyone's
in their tribe and crypto crypto is just
like a microcosm of everything else in
society everyone's in their tribe you
know when you had kurt on
he's a bsv guy yeah that's it now you
asked him well is there going to be two
or three coins that are going to you
know come out of this and be winners and
bsp is the one true god you know that
was it whereas i take that position
there's what seven thousand coins most
of them going to go away but there's
going to be you know a handful that make
it i think xrp is going to make it in
the payment sector i think bitcoin is
going to continue to be that digital
gold you know s store value and if
ethereum
if they end up figuring it out then i
think it could ultimately flip bitcoin
even it could flip bitcoin i think it
could listen you know a lot of people
say oh you're the xrp attorney and
you're hating on ether i have a higher
investment in ethereum than i do xrp
this this isn't about me this is about
what's right what's right it's about
that reaction that you had as you were
learning this right and the only
difference is i have a law degree and i
said i can do something about it
i read some word the supporters of xrp i
saw kutcher i saw madonna snoop dogg but
the most random character bill clinton
yeah they what is bill clinton and xrp
let me tell you something about ripple
you know we've already went over there
their defense lineup right their lawyers
they had bill clinton be their keynote
speaker at their annual event
on their board just this year is
a former u.s um
treasury the
her name rosie something is rios is on
the dollars and the 100 bills she was
the treasurer of the united states she's
on their board so they have top-notch
people from the industry uh not just the
crypto industry but the financial
industry are they putting bill clinton
on that list because he spoke at an
event are they putting bill clinton on
that list because he owns xrp maybe they
paid him an xrp to speak i don't know i
i think it's more about just that list
he's a fiance i don't know why former
president coming on board yeah because
because it's the right guy to have on
your side because you're dealing with a
lot of liberals on the opposing side
that want to
you know regulate the hell out of you
and a phone call from bill clinton and
even scarier phone calls from his wife
you kind of have to take that call and
say all right hillary we'll we'll leave
xrp yeah that sentence that you said man
2021 is such a trip there's a lot of
liberals that want to regulate you like
these words don't even mean anything
anymore you know who owns xrp
tim draper i know he owns xrp
the wolf of wall street jordan balfour
jordan belfort uh owns xrp and i think
uh jason derulo and maybe exhibit
maybe exhibit i think i saw him on
twitter
one of my favorite exhibit songs of all
time
back in the 90s yeah but uh uh it's a
shame uh uh
people in the rap game only for the
money and the fame extra large remember
that yeah like that was years ago
the opening was sick pat do you think
you know and john feel free to chime in
on this do you think government has
always been this overtly corrupt or are
we just finally seeing it because of
access to information i actually think
this is the most annoying time to be a
corrupt uh government official because
social media is the ultimate
great equalizer so if they control
the great equalizer which is social
media why do you think so many people
out of nowhere started saying how much
they hate facebook
i'm sorry why do you hate facebook
why do you hate facebook okay so
take twitter out does trump get elected
no
if twitter is not started your president
is today
your president today is hillary clinton
absolutely if jack dorsey and those guys
don't start today to twitter your
president it's hillary clinton today she
gave a great speech or pictures on a
wall right and she unfortunately she
would have not had the master class
which is a shame because that master
class on how to handle the laws would
have never been there right and that
newsweek magazine would have never been
there because that newsweek magazine
would have been official so mckinnon
with that great snl opening so i think i
think all of these uh uh
uh government officials who were able to
play the games back in the days like
what he's from you know what you're
showing right now with uh what do you
call it the uh
uh
uh uh is what's that 50 years ago what's
that 100 years ago
you show this right now a person who's
extremely interested in this guess
what's the first thing they're doing
what are you talking about i'm going to
google it back then you couldn't google
it right kennedy files they just buried
the kennedy files for all those years
roswell yeah so you know bob bob kirsten
or i will have he's a former chairman of
limbra and uh he sits currently i think
he as a board member for
uh i think a
consultant for bain and he was a former
president with hartford back in the days
a credible guy lots of experience in
insurance bain capitalism
mitt romney well you used to be mitt
romney that's not been a part of that
for a while but yeah bain is the top 10
biggest hedge fund in the world it's one
of the bigger ones
bob sits on our board bob and i are in
dallas last week we're having our annual
uh big board meeting that we have when
we're having conversations and during
lunch he says during dinner at the
dakotas he says how much do you read
like
every time i'm talking like how much do
you read are you always reading are you
always you know collecting data
and we're going through it and uh he
asked a question about this one guy they
used to be a big insurance trainer back
in the days and i google him and i say
tomorrow this guy says yeah
and then 30 minutes later he says you
know when i was coming up in the game i
couldn't get an answer to any question
as quickly as you just got it the edge
your generation has over me is any
question can be answered like this i had
to go to the library to find the
articles that that guy wrote to find the
book access because i couldn't even get
the book you couldn't go find a book you
have to wait a few weeks to go find who
sells an older book of a guy today
so access to information
the speed of access to information has
both positive and negative the positive
the negative to me is
we get angrier faster
we have anxiety more than ever before
stress higher before you know arguments
are higher because i want to fight you
now back in the days i had 30 minutes
until i came home to fight my wife today
i can fight you right now while i'm
driving and texting and calling it yeah
so you're literally never off the clock
you're never off the clock that that
that is like heroin man it's so
addicting right now they used to say the
average person touches this 150 times a
day 150 times a day you know it's a
couple thousand times right
but the positive side of what this has
done
is these politicians these the
establishment they hate this yeah but
that doesn't stop them well yeah but
you know the scene where joe pastone got
all these mobsters arrested and they all
walked out and one by one by one by one
yeah
i don't know i think
you know a scene like that could be
happening very soon and it needs to
happen one time that's all needs to
happen yeah to set the tone publicly
needs to happen one time needs to happen
one time all these guys talk about
when's the last time you saw you know a
person that's you know with money never
get arrested and all this other stuff
was the last time he said when's the
last time you saw politicians walking up
for manipulation behind closers and all
this other stuff i'm going to give
credit to aoc which is something i
rarely do you know what i usually said
the other day
she said i don't own any stock
why not she says i think it's not fair
for
people in office like myself
to own and invest in any stock because
we have more access to information than
the rest of you do that's a shot at
nancy
manchester united pelosi and the best
portfolio tracker
exactly the best portfolio tracker of
all time tick tockers follow what her
husband does next and boom 88 whatever
the number is unbelievable it's
unbelievable so
you know
you know there's people like that that
are going to annoy the hell out of the
establishment she's a socialist
economically we're completely on
opposite sides yeah but if there's one
thing you may be on the same side with
her
she's anti-establishment
full-on anti-establishment so i i don't
think the days of playing politics and
games and all that stuff can you pull up
what elizabeth warren and elon musk just
went through did you see that twitter
award they had that was great it was
beautiful man so elizabeth warren says
let's change the rigged tax code so the
person of the year will actually pay
taxes and stop freeloading off of
everyone else like she's trying to
get her audience that's not even the
best one he had two others
if you had the rest of it
you got to get the rest of it that's not
it and then almost responds and says
please don't call the manager on me
senator karen yeah he's like he's like
you're like that one lady that just
always gets mad at everybody she says
you're like one of my friends uh old
lady moms that were always angry yeah
that's right yeah they answered gerard
to answer your question i think pat's
100 right i think the revolving door has
always been there but they've gotten to
the point where this is just blatant
yeah i mean this is so blatant but they
did not count on
the social media i wouldn't be sitting
here right now being interviewed by you
guys if it wasn't for twitter and it
wasn't for the social media the xrp army
utilizing it jay clayton you know we've
been hitting uh cnbc uh every day they
bring jay clayton on who is a
contributor to cnbc and they'll they ask
him a question that just says hey that
your critics say there's a conflict and
he goes i'm not going to comment and
then they brought him on to dave again
and she goes listen everywhere i go it's
the same question you know are you going
to address the ethics issue and he goes
i'm not going to talk about pending
litigation there's no pitting litigation
about your ethics yeah right yeah like
we're questioning your integrity and you
won't defend yourself that doesn't sound
like you you were the former sec
chairman of the united states securities
exchange commission and you can't answer
a few questions but but this is kind of
where i'm going with that is like this
is what it has scares me and half
infuriates me i feel like you know
learning history from before i was alive
that at least these people had the the
good sense to try to hide their
corruption exactly there was a fear of
public retribution now we may not have
had access to the information but there
was a fear like oh my god these people
find out we're in big trouble that just
doesn't exist anymore i mean what
they're doing with with the you know
what the ftc is doing with with the
pfizer shots and yeah we'll let you know
what's in them we'll let you know what
we knew in 55 years now it's 75 years
on its base point i mean that's just so
insulting it's so infuriating that you
you threatened people's livelihoods you
said you got to get this or you're not
going to be allowed to fly you're not
going to you're we're going to get you
fired from your job unless you get this
thing okay what's in it we'll tell you
in 75 years what
like
bro what like and it's not just that
it's over and over and over again the
overt corruption
that they just they do it and then they
move on and there's literally there's
this error of like yeah yeah we did it
what are you going to do about it how
many times does jp morgan and goldman
sachs been fined for manipulating gold
and silver markets
and it just keeps happening and
happening you know if you make a billion
you're willing to pay a hundred million
dollars yeah it's a good business model
it absolutely is yeah so you know the
the inferior and i don't know is it so
is that on the public we have access to
this information but we don't hold these
people accountable is that on us
is this have we just has this
environment just created a new brand of
overtly corrupt politicians that just
don't care what the public thinks they
feel insulated from any sort of i mean
maxine waters literally told people to
go burn down american cities
literally did it's like get out there if
you see if you see people that you
politically disagree with in restaurants
make it hard on them
you know that's terrorism that's that's
the literal definition of terrorism well
i mean using violence to promote
politics is the literal definition of
terrorism again that that is why that is
why the people want to see an
anti-establishment in the white house
that's why half the country wants to see
an anti-establishment person in the
white house to see if they're going to
hold those people accountable that's the
biggest part look you know
they say people get into politics with
the right intentions i'm going to go
correct this injustice that's happening
and you're in it for a year three years
five years eight years or elections
coming up you need a favor you give this
guy the favor he gives you the money you
get reelected now you're part of the
establishment now your crusade your
cause you were a true believer you're no
longer statesman now you're officially
what
you're part of the establishment you're
done and they're gonna hold you to it
for the rest of your life it's game over
with right okay
this is why uh a person that's coming
that's not part of the establishment
that annoys the hell out of everybody
is what america needs today because if
they talk about the stuff that these
guys don't they go to the same country
clubs they go to the same parties they
go ahead and get at the same time
fraternities in college you want to pull
out what musk said this is the whole
twitter says stop projecting you remind
me uh of uh when i was a kid and my
friend's angry mom would just randomly
yell at everyone for no reason please
don't call the manager on me senator
karen just look at her she looks like
she's not really that happy with her
life you know she looks bitter and
upset and this idea that elon musk
doesn't pay taxes it's just like again
it it
it's just such gaslighting it's such
nonsensical
how much do you think he pays payroll
taxes alone how many jobs have they got
that's what i'm saying that's why i want
to know how many jobs have the
infrastructure that that yeah yeah yeah
like what what have they added
you know i i i can tell you i live i
grew up in detroit single mother welfare
food stamps
growing up i did not hate
the wealthier rich man i wanted to know
what he knew yeah what can you tell me
that i don't know so that i can do that
this class warfare has just gotten out
of hand you know what i mean well
they're doing it on purpose it's like
can you imagine that we're going to only
tax unrealized gains of billionaires
unrealized gains
unrealized gains unrealized gains did
that come out of your mouth
that you're going to attack someone for
unrealized gains so so elon musk detects
on the moon
elon musk's stock price goes through the
roof we're going to tax him but then
when it crashes when there's a recall or
something he can't write it off did you
did you see the article about what's
going on in la right now because you
know the all these guys that are saying
this stuff sometimes they say these
unrealized games defund the police it's
a good idea and then they're like oh
we didn't say the republicans said
defund the police no you came up with
defunded police yes and now they're all
increasing their budget to hire cops
because in la did you see what happened
in l.a at the grove like what they have
around the grove did you did you see
what the type in la grove fence did you
see what the lapd put out for travelers
coming to la like don't wear anything
flashy if somebody if somebody tries to
rob you yeah try to negotiate them just
give them what they want look at this
this is cnn famous l.a shopping center
adds barbed wire-like fence to deter
smash and grabs wow this is this isn't
we're talking about cnn here look at
this this doesn't make any sense
businesses are worried today in l.a fyi
yesterday somebody sent the story saying
uh uh a famous uh look at that look at
that that's crazy yeah that doesn't make
any sense by the way
did you pull up the apple store in
portland after that watch this the wire
fencing in place didn't fully deter a
robbery at the grove on november 22nd
when a group of 18 to 20 looters used
sledgehammers and an electric bicycle to
smash into the complex nordstrom after
hours they managed to steal at least
five thousand of merchandise and cost
fifteen thousand dollars in damages
through police later recover merchandise
arrested three people in connection with
the burglary the video somebody sent me
a video yesterday so check this out guy
walks in takes stuff he's at walmart
they can't say anything to him he just
walks out he's not running out he just
walks out then he walks out he ties his
shoelaces outside
in front of the stairs you're
you you just stole you're supposed to
run that's the protocol he's dying in
shoelaces
i'm not going to get arrested home so
someone said oh people are
leaving l.a i said dude you have not
seen the exodus california's about to
experience it hasn't started yet people
think it started because elon you know
all these guys have joe rogan he's not
even started yet just wait just wait
uh to see what happens there but uh yeah
so these policies that you're talking
about by the way i want to look at the
stock act that came up with some people
are talking about that aoc has money and
all this other stuff us news did an
article saying what are congress members
trading
uh in 2013 a amendment to the stock act
came up made some changes clouding the
transparency and
accessibility congress members financial
transactions most notably
removed the requirement for electronic
filing in a searchable sortable database
of transactions however one useful
aspect of the legislation which requires
members to publicly report
financial transactions and stocks bonds
and other assets within 45 days that
remains which is good this is why people
know what pelosi owns but but there are
still people that are skirting that like
republican tommy tubberball the
ex-football coach he he refuses he
refuses to admit what he sells all the
time like he got caught uh selling
alibaba stock months after he sold it
now he's got uh by the way for people
that don't want to look it up tommy
tubble has some massive short puts on
both apple microsoft and uh first
quarter of 2022. i think uh
became a true three trillion if you
believe if you believe tommy tupperware
he thinks that the first quarter of 2022
is going to be brutal
i share that opinion so this is
incredible you shared that opinion i i
have the opinion i also fair disclosure
had the opinion that bitcoin was going
to run up by now but i think it's going
to run up in the first quarter followed
by a massive sell-off on crypto um
uh tech stocks how bad how bad do you
think it's going to be 20 20 30 30 so
you think bitcoin's gonna drop to what
25 30. my prediction bitcoin hits over a
hundred thousand and drops back to where
it is today
so okay yeah so it's you're not saying
it's going to drop to 20 or 15 or 30 or
anything like that i mean it could i
think it's going to be a massive i think
there's too much money in it right now
but after the run-up i think the i think
it could go from 150 back to 50.
yeah that's not that's not uh that's not
something that's going to move the the
uh the long play guys what does a
pom say nearly 85 percent of uh bitcoin
owners never sell their bitcoin they
keep it they just sit on it so these are
not guys that are churning and burning
of course the other 15 is just buying it
as a absolutely stock and they're you
know pumping down but
many of the true believers are hanging
on to it why do you think the first
quarter of 2022 is going to be so bad or
are the holiday revenues not going to be
what they normally are is that what the
idea is here like why on earth i mean it
could start to be happening now i i
obviously no one can time the market you
know i mean i just think that senators
seem to do it pretty good well that's
true uh they're talented they're smart
they have degrees from carter's columbia
university pretty good
yeah it's it's a different kind of a
world they're living in
uh uh uh let me let me see which other
story i wanted to bring up here before
bye but did you hear about keanu reeves
what the keanu ruiz talked about yeah so
interesting uh take on keanu reeves uh
did you see that one girl whose story
went viral yeah with the
how awesome is her mom's like i'm about
to take a picture with keanu reeves
she's like i have no idea what this guy
is but i'll take a picture with you so
whatever yeah what do you mean
it goes viral here's keanu reeves okay
matrix star keanu reeves owns crypto
skeptical of nfds says we cannot have
metaverse be invented by facebook famous
hollywood actor cryptocurrency members
are going to fundamental tokens during
the interview reeves commented on the
metaverse on facebook the social media
giant that recently changed his name to
meta can we just not have metaverse be
invented by facebook he said on the
subject of non-fungible tokens reefs was
asked whether he has seen matrix nfts
for the upcoming matrix resurrection
movie he admitted that he has not seen
them and wondered if he and moss are
getting paid at all for them
when asked what he thought about the
concept of digital scarcity reeves
laughed and added that they are still
easily reproduced what are your thoughts
on nfts well i
i think the whole metaverse is is i'm
trying to get my
head around it i really am but like for
example nike you're going to be able to
go in the metaverse and go into a nike
store in the metaverse and buy a
non-fungible token and then come out to
the real world and then buy that real
world shoe
yeah like it's it's
an interplay but i mean do i have some
mana some sand i have some of those
tokens but
uh i'm still trying to get my head
around it you know the
buying land in the metaverse patches
told you man if you're on your phone
2500 3500 times a day the next
the next uh
the next progression is in the phone man
and um again
the dopamine is going to be something
that our brains are not going to be able
to get off of you're going to be able to
live
your life as your idealized self in the
in the metaverse you want to be six foot
five you want to have abs you want to
dunk you want you you want your
girlfriend to look like barbie all of
that's possible in the metaverse it's
not possible in the real world so what
do you two think in
ft's i think it's a beautiful way to
launder money
yeah i don't think it's going away i
think it's been around for a while i
mean if you played any video games and
you would buy the additional stuff that
would come with it buy a weapon for five
bucks buy this for 10 bucks buy this for
20 bucks
i remember one time me and my friends
okay stephen awful were in where were we
we're in panama okay
and we're at the uh panama canal and my
friend is sitting down his phone's
playing this game i don't know what he
clash of something so he's playing this
game clash of titans clash of types
and i said so what's going on here and
one the guy says you know he spent
already five thousand dollars on that
game i said how much he said five
thousand i said what are you doing with
five thousand dollars on this game
i said get video games like i remember
street fighter was 74.95 i remember when
he came out as fast as he says oh no
this is different let me tell you what
i'm buying look at the weapon look at
this look at that look at this
what are you talking about so if a
40 year old decca millionaire which is
that friend of mine is that's exactly
the situation he's in
if he's spending five thousand dollars
on a game he's essentially buying
non-fungible tokens so it's been around
for a long long time
it's officially now at a point where
they're trying to get the rest of the
world to know that this is the direction
we're going well here's nothing you can
do about here's what's screwy about what
you just said
so what you do in those games is you buy
time
because as you as you increase your your
castle as you increase your land it
takes longer to farm it takes longer to
build up clouds not yet
clash of titans is better but clash of
clans is good too the uh anyway so the
the uh the point i'm trying to make is
that in the metaverse one of the things
that that if you want to get real trippy
twilight zoney
the logical conclusion of this is
downloading your
consciousness
into the metaverse living forever as
your idealized self
as long as you can afford to buy more
time right
so as long as you can afford and that's
a movie five more times what was the
movie
time i don't know what yeah it was
called yeah so i mean but that's
that's uh i don't think it's going away
look there's two things that's going to
drive nfts and the meta here's what it
is number one
what is your system
when you lay in bed and you close your
eyes where do you go to
so so you're either thinking about
issues you're dealing with
you're thinking about your kids your
husband your wife your girlfriend your
boyfriend your mom's health your dad's
self your business a job interview a
project
something
or you're fantasizing about something
yeah like oh my gosh how's it gonna be
when i go to europe and my your brain
just goes right okay that's a meta
essentially you're living in la la land
and we've been doing this for a while
except it's your own meta that i cannot
be a part of sure it's only one person's
matter it's your bet and i'm concerned
about the medium
i don't i don't know if i want to go to
history
yeah it's real sticky in my mouth
okay but but that is a form of meta
right and here's the other part why i
don't think this is going away
i think you know like somebody said what
an idiot who the hell would spend five
thousand dollars it's called competition
man capitalism is based on competition
we like to compete we want to do better
we want to be on our leaders bulletin we
want to be ranked we want to have
something to say here's what i am as
long as your imagination doesn't go away
and as long as competition is going to
be the main currency
nftn meadow's not going to go away dude
it's immortality it's so much bigger
than that yeah it's immortality if you
had the option and if you had the
resources to live forever your family
live forever
would you do it
i mean it's not even a hypothetical
question it's maybe a matter of
technological advancement
i couldn't talk about it i wrote a book
about it the fiction book you've read
the book the book is about
that that's partly a meta and it took me
10 years to finish this book and we're
right now we just finished it right now
we're pitching it to uh publishers we
just
finished the what do you call it the the
marketing uh for the book and we'll be
going to different publishers to see
what direction we're going to go with
this but that is essentially what you're
talking about what happens when your
meta life is so much better than your
real life that's the that's the problem
everybody's going to be
the john you may want to put down my
clothes it's not a problem of the of the
system it's
the backbone of the system
your idealized self your dream world is
going to be so much better than the real
world you're never coming out
there's going to be people who
become
david thoreau go to the woods live
deliberately i want to feel
i want i want to look at the real sky i
want to breathe the real air and they're
going to there's going to be those half
of society that they're going to be real
they're going to want to go skydiving
they want real danger they want to feel
real things they want to have
unprotected sex they want to feel life
and then there's going to be people that
are in the metaverse that are safe
they're totally controlled they can't
say anything bad they have to acquiesce
all their freedom to whatever you know
controlling organism but they get the
trade-off as they get to be their
idealized self right they get to do
whatever they've ever dreamed of doing
that they can't do in the real world
they can do it here and that's it that
the serotonin and the dopamine that
that's going to cause i mean right now
you've got guys that you know there's uh
there's
a great comedian that i know mike
sicoley unbelievable guy he goes uh
my life is so much better in grand theft
auto than my regular life yeah and i die
a hundred times an hour
like he's like he's like i die a hundred
times an hour gta my life is so much
better in the game what percentage of
people do you think
uh prefer their imaginary life over
their real life what do you think that
is
i mean it's high of course
why do people do drugs why do people do
alcohol to escape reality i mean we've
been wanting to escape reality for
a long time most people's escaping of
reality is video games or you know
smoking weed or doing ecstasy and doing
whatever they do that is their form i
just don't want to deal with the life i
currently have and there's nothing i can
do about it
so you're you're bitter about it you
have a way to escape it so
that is part of the motive and the
attraction i can escape it and it's a
different form of a drug and i'm going
to be addicted to it that's just kind of
how this thing's going to be i i think
the drug analogy is the perfect
denominator are you are your parents
still alive if you don't want me no okay
imagine if their consciousness were
uploaded to the metaverse and you can go
to the metaverse and have dinner with
your mother whenever you wanted to
what would that be worth to you a lot
especially if she was cooking
would would it
would it would it matter would it matter
to you that the food you were eating
wasn't real
no probably not right not if it was her
chicken and dumplings and cornbread
making me hungry man
i mean that that's
you know look we think about the crazy
things and we think about like you know
the ability to fly and all this like
fantasy stuff and that's definitely part
of it but then there's that actual that
realization of like you know what man
like if my parents yeah
if
you know if my parents consciousness
gets uploaded i mean look my parents are
a little bit older i go home twice a
year if my parents live another 10 years
i got 20 times to see my mother 20 2-0
and that's the whole reason to work
people the whole reason to work the
whole reason to put up with the
and make money is because money's worth
time right and if you can double that
and see your parents four times a year
you double the amount of time you have
with them the metaverse you can see them
forever right forever yeah how many
people want to have a conversation with
their deceased parents that's that's the
price point i mean listen the whole part
about being a born again what is the
idea that you're eventually going to see
the people you love that are no longer
here with you well
in heaven yeah meta is a form of a
secular heaven is how it's being sold
but
i want to wrap up with this story in a
week off it's on page two at the bottom
of page two if you want to look at that
uh
uh it's a cnbc story own everything but
bubble assets tech and crypto recommends
institutional investor hall of famer
rich bernstein which we know who he is
he has got a big reputation he's he's a
winner he's done well for himself on one
side he says we have all that i would
call the bubble assets tech innovation
disruption cryptocurrencies
this is rich bernstein who ran strategy
at merrill lynch on the other side of
this seesaw you have literally
everything else in the world i think if
you're looking at 2022 into 2023 you
want to be in the everything else in the
world side of that seesaw his number one
pick is energy a group he listed as a
top play coming into 2021 earlier this
year bernstein called oil
the most ignored bull market bernstein
also sees cryptocurrency as a major
problem last june he warned the rush to
own bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
was becoming dangerously parabolic
cryptos are the biggest financial bubble
ever in the history this is just a
monster one do you agree with them
well it depends on the timing like when
he says so for example if bitcoin goes
from 47 000 to 150 000 and then crashes
is he right well i guess he is but
kathy wood takes the opposite right she
says we're not in a bubble right now of
arc investing and um so it all it all
comes perspective i don't think we've
seen the parabolic run on bitcoin that
he's describing and i certainly don't
think it's the biggest bubble ever do i
think everything is in a bubble when you
pump this much liquidity
into the economy then sure you're going
to create bubbles and so it's all a
matter of perspective do i think that
there's going to be some type of crash
um
some point next year yes you know is
that the later half is that the first
half the first quarter i don't know i
wish i did
um but um
i think he's right that we're we're
headed for a major correction i just
don't know when you know what i mean you
know we talk about the tech bubble was
tech really a bubble i mean
was it a bubble because look at what
look at what apple is 99 it was what i'm
saying look at what apple is oh yeah
yeah look at what microsoft are there
there's a difference between a bubble
and disruptive
technology there's a difference between
a bubble and changing industries you
know like if somebody was like back in
the day you know a car
cost five hundred dollars a ford model t
well i can get a horse for twenty five
dollars i'm never spending five hundred
dollars for a car that's an as9 you know
and then you know there's million dollar
cars now right that drives him when he
gets bored on the weekends like is that
a bubble was is that parabolic or is it
changing technology like
i think you you said it best it's a
matter of perspective of time right like
if ripple if you guys settle if you guys
win this case and it goes up to a dollar
fifty what's crazy is people be like
it's just a two hundred it's a two
hundred percent like like that's not
even good in crypto anymore it's like
why
ten times twenty yeah if it's not if
it's not nine thousand x it's not worth
my time like it's it's so in that aspect
of it there's a speculation right bubble
but i don't think i mean if you're
oil man i mean with exxon with the
activists that they have like yeah look
always be in energy always be in things
that people use it's not sexy you know
but you got to be in things that people
use but do you think crypto is going
away to me bubble means it's going away
yeah is real estate is real estate in a
bubble right now
i think real estate is a mathematical
formula you know meaning like if
interest rates go up and real estate's
going to take a hit you know goldman
sachs is predicting rates are going to
go up seven times in 2022. wow that's a
lot of times when goldman says seven
times uh rates are good there's no way
oh listen i i
in a midterm election year you think
that look at look at the political
pressure that he's dealing with you
think that
did you hear what biden said yesterday
says republicans i just want to tell you
it's going to be a bad midterm election
for you did you hear him say that yeah
okay i think they're getting wrecked
they're getting wrecked well the number
is 63 i think it's 61 or 63 the record
held by the most seats to flip and the
person that owns the record is his
former boss barack obama so we're going
to see whether he's going to flip that
many like he's going to lose that many
seeds well i i hope they lose the seats
because i want to see gary gensler and
committee answering some questions it'd
be interesting to see that taking place
how can people help put pressure pot
what can people do they're listening to
this help put public pressure on them so
that this investigation happens if they
go to crypto uh www.crypto.us
cryptolaw.us if they go to that there's
a tab in the law.us yes if they go to
that there's a tab connect to congress
and that goes to your senators and your
congress representatives and you can you
can put on pressure simply say you want
an investigation into this you want the
sec to come answer questions under oath
these guys are skating it you know their
investigation into specifically
investigation into the sec and the
filing of this case and the way it went
down and the conflicts of interest
conflicts and here's the thing
only good can come from an independent
investigation because when the let's say
pat gerard let's say that there was no
actual crime but when the appearance of
impropriety rises to the level that it
destroys public confidence credibility
yeah right then if you do an
investigation and it's fair and it's
independent and you come back and say no
crime was committed no quit pro quo you
know uh but they could have done
disclosures done this better fine if if
there is a crime committed if there was
a quid pro quo then justice is done what
was the tweet that you said yesterday
you had a tweet yesterday hey let's
let's uh let the truth hey let the truth
fall where it may it's just a matter of
time well john i'm glad we were able to
make this work absolutely thank you so
much we
never do podcasts on wednesday but we
did it because we wanted to have a sit
down we can have right
i hope the audience has enjoyed it
and learned just as much as we have uh
folks if you don't follow john on
twitter he posts stuff there regularly
and he's very active i suggest you go
follow him on twitter what's your handle
on twitter by the way johnnydeaton1 john
e
deaton
okay john eden one on twitter you can
find them there as well as we put the
link there crypto law dot u s crypto law
that us to follow what's going on over
here john appreciate you for coming out
folks tomorrow we are with danielle de
martino booth same time tomorrow podcast
three times this week we won't be doing
it next week but tomorrow we'll be at
danielle take care guys bye-bye bye-bye
you